[Music]
the original lego movie had a huge twist
that ultimately ended up being about a
father and son bonding with one another
over a shared love for all things Lego
naturally this wowed critics and the
revelation carried a lot of weight with
it that added depth of the work and
elevated it above most animated movies
the lego movie to the second part is no
different and throughout this video I'll
be discussing attending and the meaning
behind it there will be heavy spoilers
here so if you don't want to know
anything about the film then I highly
suggest that you turn off now but for
everyone else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I watch it so you don't
have to do the film jumps between the
real world and Lego imagination and
Finn's head several times and the piece
is ultimately about his relationship
with his little sister Bianca Bianca has
begun playing with Finn's Lego and
similar to his father in the first film
he sees this is wrong and that the only
way to properly play with them is his
way I myself have a younger sister and
found this quite easy to relate to as
I'm sure many others will Big Brothers
and Big Sisters tend to look down on
their siblings and are sort of overly
protective over their toys and
ultimately it's probably to their own
detriment a younger brother or sister is
someone that you can really have an
amazing childhood with but for some
reason we tend to block their mouths and
in the end that the lego movie 2 is
about Finn overcoming this and learning
to share with his sister after realizing
they will always have each other
beautifully the lego world reflects this
conflict early on with the duplo
invaders from Bianca's world invading
bricksburg and turning it into
apocalypse burg Emmett has dreams of our
mom get in and this implies that Finn
fears his mother may one day take away
his toys if he and Bianca can not get
along Emmet wants to move into his dream
home with Lucy but this is stopped when
he and his friends are kidnapped this
kickstart an adventure that is packed
with pop-culture references awesome
moments and the group me a new character
called Rex danger best whilst trying to
make it to the antagonising sister
system Luci is really swept up by the
rugged and dashing danger vest and Emmet
starts to take on some of his mannerisms
to try and impress his girlfriend as
they head towards the system to save the
day we learned that in fact the sister
system was trying to broker peace with
apocalypse burg but that they were just
very bad at communicating here and this
of course is a metaphor for the
relationship between Finn and Bianca who
are unable to truly get on the same page
as one another even though they want the
same thing
Emmet mistakingly stops the peace and in
the real world this is reflected by Finn
who destroys Bianca's creations their
mother orders them to put their toys
away and this is our mom getting coming
to fruition in the Lego world Emmet
learns that Rex is in fact a twisted
version of himself from the future that
fell into the clothes dryer Rex does get
the better of Emma and knocks him into
the dry attentio that he will still
exist and that her paradox will not be
created
however Emma isn't your ordinary brick
and he fights back ensuring that you
won't turn out like Rex there's a big
showdown and Rex in the end disappears
because Emmet finally overcomes his
inner demons this is mirrored in the
real world in which Finn and Bianca
finally decide to play together and
after getting their toys returned they
stop hammam getting the to build
together as Lucy and Emmet rekindle
their relationship in the Lego world
there's a couple of cool reveals and
Easter eggs that I don't want to spoil
but in the end this is ultimately about
beating the mind state within yourself
that stops you from interacting with
others and leads you down a less
fun-filled path it's a beautiful message
that is arguably just as poignant as the
first film and really allowed me to step
into the shoes of Finn and remember what
I was like as a child at sort of
secluded myself when I could have had
more fun playing with my little sister
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the film and what you took from it do
you prefer this message over the first
film and what was your favorite of the
two
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and make sure you check out my breakdown
of the Avengers and game super bowl
trailer which would be linked at the end
this is the channel for people who were
mad into movies so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
[Music]
you